you're not going to believe this next
clip this this is just unbelievable it I
expected that it would happen but I
didn't know that it would be John
barrasso last week during a whacked
interview with Sean Hannity Donald Trump
talked about telepathic declassification
of documents Donald Trump said during
his interview with Sean Hannity that his
president he could think about
declassifying a document and that
declassifies the document don't believe
me you don't have to here's the video
send it you know there's different
people say different things but as I
understand there doesn't have to be if
you're the president of the United
States you can declassify just by saying
it's Declassified even by thinking about
it because you're sending it to
Mar-A-Lago or to wherever you're sending
it there it is just by thinking about
declassification you can declassify
documents this is absolutely sickening
insane
absurd comical in some weird way well
Republican senator John barrasso went on
ABC's This Week With George
Stephanopoulos yesterday
Stephanopoulos rhetorically asks him
about telepathic declassification
and barasso doesn't even say that's
that's absurd George look at this this
is unbelievable oh I want to ask you
about the investigation of Donald
Trump's handling of classified
information even though his lawyers Who
provided no evidence that he
Declassified the documents the Trump
said this week that as president he
could declassify documents by thinking
about it do you agree with that
I've not heard that one before George
like I tell you in terms of National
Security folks
he's answering it like it's a real
question
he's answering it like it's a real thing
telepathic declassification commence
we have to always use Extreme Caution
I'm one of the Foreign Relations
Committee we deal with classified
information all of the time and really
and have you ever on that Foreign
Relations Committee
dealt with the telepathic
declassification of documents we're
always very careful I don't know what a
what anything about the rules for under
President declassifies I mean maybe the
rules allow telepathic declassification
maybe they don't documents and
information
what I do know is what I'd like to see
from a senate standpoint is I'd like to
see the Department of Justice come to us
and show us in a classified setting what
the information is what they've done I
thought this the rate at the former
president's home and now you'll see
Stephanopoulos realize that barrasso's
lost the plot and try to get him back on
track by saying Senator what I said is
absurd never seen anything like that
before clearly and it's becoming so I
want to get a briefing so that we can
then be informed to see what actually
happened here that that was a rhetorical
question you know that a president can't
declassify documents by thinking about
it why can't you say so
no I don't think a president can
declassify documents by saying so by
thinking about it why does it by saying
so no by thinking about it what is wrong
with this guy is this guy so under the
thumb of trumpism that he can't just
come out and say George of course you
can't think about documents and
declassify them of course of course that
first and foremost I also am concerned
about how the search warrant was
approved oh okay well now we have a
conversation to talk about but 60
seconds about well listen you know we
should figure out what the documents are
and then determine what are the methods
we're talking about telepathically
Declassified declassifying documents
here oh yeah no you can't do that you
know that's true I guess you can't do
that these people are off the deep end
and if you think this is bad just wait
until you see what I have coming up
after the break remember you can find
all of these clips that we play on the
show on our Instagram search David
packman show on Instagram
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the U.S alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below